You're studying comedy,
do you have any questions for me?
Is there anything I can do to help you?
Okay, so the biggest question I have,
I remember I was listening
to your podcast once,
because literally for Spotify,
you guys were like my #1 podcast
I think 10,000 minutes of
me listening to you guys.
Yeah.
Oh, that's so sweet, that's so sweet.
Thank you.
Yeah, so a question I had
you said that when you
first started doing improv
you would get really nervous
and I'm pretty sure a teacher
of yours had to pull you aside
and be like, "Calm down."
And I was wondering how
you got through that
and how you became who you are now.
I think a lot of people
and myself included think
your job is to become funny
and to become this person who's known
or a celebrity or whatever
you want to call it.
And I think it's not that.
I think if you're doing it the right way,
you're figuring out a way
to become the person you already were
in an unusual situation.
So when you say at home
and with your friends
you're Richard Pryor,
and then you get up on stage.
Yes, that's the trick, is figuring out
how can I bring that
person who's funny at home?
How can I bring that person up on stage?
And that takes a little
doing and takes time.
But the good news is you have that person,
that person's fully formed.
That person is the person you are
with your friends and family.
What's tricky is when people say,
I'm not funny with my friends and family,
but I want to be a comedian.
You're like, well,
(laughs)
I don't think that's going to work
but I do think that
that's just called time.
If you spend enough
time in front of people,
I mean you can watch the first,
you know year of me on
late night television.
And I look like a guy who's trying
to do a good job as a comedy host.
What happens is through the sheer
just amount of shows we had to do
and the sheer stress and whatever it was,
that all fell away,
and soon I just felt
like I was always on TV
so the real me came out.
The real me ended up coming out.
And so that's what you do
is you get your stage time
until the real person comes out.
That's such good advice
Does that make sense?
No, it makes perfect sense.
Yeah, is it okay if I charge you for it?
No.
Well, since like I'm a student,
so I don't have much money in general.
I'd prefer if you didn't.
Well, what I like to do is
it'll be like a student loan
and it will be a very high rate.
What
Not a good rate.
What happens if she doesn't pay?
You already gave her the advice.
(laughs)
Yeah, well I will repossess
your comedy career whatever
Oh okay
career in comedy,
I will come and I will repossess it,
(laughing)
or I'll say I now have
80% of it, you know,
it's a really,
look you never should
have gotten on this call.
This was a big mistake.
'Cause now, Chelby, it's just like,
I just have a huge controlling
interest in your career,
and there's no way out.
There's really no way out.